[Música]
buenas tardes
buenas tardes por favor levanten la mano
quienes son líderes levanten la mano
quienes son líderes
bien muy bien
hace 14 años exactamente
yo al igual que muchos de ustedes no
levanten la mano cuando me hicieron la
pregunta en un taller
no sé si han escuchado el término
perdices en la vida hay cosas que
sabemos que sabemos
en la vida hay cosas que sabemos que no
sabemos por ejemplo yo sé que no sé
ingeniería nuclear
pero lo interesante y preste la atención
a lo que voy a decir en la vida hay
cosas que no sabemos que no sabemos
y ese momento hace 14 años en un taller
de liderazgo de servicio
no sabía yo tenía un superpoder como
esos superhéroes
y ese superpoder se llama influencia
influencia
y me di cuenta
que todos nosotros todos los seres
humanos cada mañana debemos tomar una
decisión de cómo usar esa influencia
en primer lugar sabemos que hay
influencia negativa y hay influencia
positiva
no la pregunta qué es desde hace 14 años
me hago cada mañana frente al espejo en
la mañana cuando me estoy preparando
para mi día el huerto cómo vas a usar tu
influencia hoy día
la vas a usar para servir
o la voy a usar para servirme a mí mismo
y desde ese taller
mi vida cambio ha marcado un antes y un
después
porque en ese taller aprendí una nueva
definición de liderazgo que les invito
también a ustedes a que la adopten
bueno la definición de liderazgo es esta
cada vez que busques influenciar el
pensamiento el comportamiento o el
desarrollo de otros estás tomando un rol
de líder
cómo es eso no necesito ser un jefe en
mi empresa para ser un líder no necesito
tener a cargo un equipo para hacer un
líder no eres líder porque tienes este
súper poder de la influencia
no necesito en mi familia a ser un padre
de familia o madre de familia y ser
líder de la uar no como hijo tienes este
super poder de la influencia
por eso es que
el liderazgo es influencia
el liderazgo es influencia si quieres
tener una definición con una palabra de
liderazgo es influencia
y la pregunta que les invito a empezar a
reflexionar es cómo estás influenciando
a los que te rodean
serás una influencia positiva
serás una influencia negativa
bueno a reflexionar
muy bien
algo que aprendí también en este taller
de liderazgo de servicio es que como ser
humano puedo ejercer dos roles de
liderazgo un rol en mi familia un rol de
vida y otro rol en mi ocupación en mi
trabajo como estudiante etcétera en mi
familia como hijo
puedo influenciar a mis padres para algo
tan simple como para definir decidir
dónde nos vamos de vacaciones o también
puede influenciar a mi madre en algo un
poco más delicado
puedo influenciar mi madre aquí
quite de su corazón el orgullo y perdone
a mis padres para no divorciarse
en mi trabajo
como asistente
o auxiliar puede influenciar a mi jefe
para algo tan simple como una nueva idea
una nueva estrategia o puedo influenciar
a mi jefe en algo más complicado y
delicado como no malinterpretar un
comportamiento aparentemente negativo de
un empleado lo cual pueda definir su
persistencia o no en el trabajo
eso es influencia
y ahora tengo una mala noticia y una
buena noticia
una muy mala noticia para ustedes pero
también una buena noticia cualquier en
1er
lo mal exacto y esta es la mala
estamos viviendo una crisis mundial de
liderazgo malas noticias
no solamente en bolivia no solamente
sudamérica en todo el mundo hay una
crisis de liderazgo
y solo basta ver las noticias nacionales
o internacionales para darte cuenta
de que mucha gente tiene valores
perdón
valores abandonados
personas en posiciones de liderazgo
están dispuestos a abandonar sus valores
supuestamente no negociables valores
fundamentales por el poder el ego la
codicia etcétera
confianzas traicionadas
manipulación y explotación
cometidas por gente de poder
y de posición
y definitivamente una falta de
integridad y respeto tolerancia y todo
esto
está contaminando las relaciones
envenenando las relaciones a todo nivel
familias en empresas en universidades
grupo de amigos están envenenando
y esa es la mala noticia
existe una desesperada necesidad y un
modelo diferente de liderazgo
un liderazgo desde el corazón donde el
amor el respeto la comprensión la
tolerancia sea lo primero
la buena noticia
la buena noticia es que hay una
esperanza
hay una solución a esto y hay un
movimiento mundial y mi invitación es
que ustedes ahora y tal vez más que una
habitación es un desafío que se una en
este movimiento que lo llamamos el
liderazgo de servicio y de qué se trata
esto de liderazgo de servicio porque la
primera vez que escuché esto dije
nuestro contrario cómo puede haber
liderazgo y servicio si es posible y es
posible desde
una posición personal y una decisión
personal de servir antes de servirme de
los demás de servir a las personas antes
de servirme a mí mismo y pucha es muy
muy difícil 14 años y sigo luchando
porque cada día
cedo a la tentación
de mi orgullo
de mis miedos de mi el centrismo pero
gracias a dios no estoy como ayer estoy
mejor estoy avanzando
y esta es la organización este es un
gran mentor puse la foto ahí porque tal
vez muchos lo reconocen el famoso que en
planchar un gurú la organización se
llama lilia existe si el término una
empresa consultora de came blanchard
companies y se llama eso un modelo de
liderazgo de servicio
y de qué se trata todo esto de ser un
líder del servicio
tiene que ver con no solamente un
ejercicio intelectual o de leer un libro
o de pasar un curso tiene que ser un una
cirugía a corazón abierto lo que llama
que es un cambio de corazón desde
adentro
esta organización que me acaricie en un
estudio y dice que el mundo hay más de
22 mil libros sobre el liderazgo miles
de programas de entrenamiento de glasgow
pero muy la mayoría de ellos se enfocan
en el hacer del líder y eso es muy bueno
importante destrezas habilidades
recursos sin embargo hay menos de cinco
programas y sin que en el ser en el
corazón de la persona
y de eso vamos a hablar
si queremos ser buenos líderes diversa
efectivos donde nuestra influencia
realmente impacte vidas y haga una
diferencia a la vida a los demás
necesitamos trabajar primero en nosotros
mismos esa es la base
necesitamos lo que llamamos el auto
liderazgo ese es el primer paso
si quieres tú ser un líder en cualquiera
de tu vida necesitas primero
experimentar una transformación personal
un cambio de perspectiva
grandes estudios han dicho que se
requiere del 50 por ciento de tu tiempo
para trabajar en ti mismo
y si yo pido que levanten la mano todo
mucho ya yo personalmente no invierto
50% de mi tiempo en mi auto o liderazgo
y mi desarrollo personal pero eso es
vale la pena tomar conciencia lo
importante que es trabajar en ti mismo
en tus pensamientos en tu caja de
herramientas como decía presida
y ha habido muchos estudios
grandes universidades del mundial como
stanford y el harvard grandes empresas
de investigación como gallup se han
hecho esta pregunta y han dicho cuál es
la habilidad principal la principal
destreza cualidad que necesita una
persona para ser exitosa en su vida
cual cree
conciencia
autoconciencia y qué es eso de
autoconciencia conocerte a ti mismo
conocerte a ti mismo
autoevaluar te reconocer cuál es tu
esencia reconocer dónde estás y si estás
conforme en ese lugar dónde estás o
quieres moverte a un lugar deseado
identificar si hay un espacio y tomar la
acción si quieres hacer algo para
acercarte a ese lugar deseado en
cualquiera de tu vida
autoconciencia quiere decir otra toma de
conciencia es darte cuenta de algo que
antes no te dabas cuenta
darte cuenta de las consecuencias de tus
decisiones en el logro de tus objetivos
darte cuenta los resultados de tus
pensamientos si te limitan o te
potencian
eso es
este tema de la toma de conciencia que
yo lo experimenté desde hace 14 años
sigo trabajando en mi inteligencia
emocional en trabajar en ese mociones en
mis sentimientos y de qué forma
voy a gestionarlos para que me ayuden a
lograr mis objetivos en la toma de
conciencia es algo tan simple como que
estoy parado en la esquina de la plaza
con semáforo rojo y de repente viene por
atrás una persona y me pecho me empuja
me pisa en ese momento me emocionalidad
mis pensamientos son muy positivos me
molesta me duele me estoy en esos
segundos imagínense visualizaciones
segundos estoy por darme la vuelta
y tal vez para decirle a esta persona
oye jovencito deja de chatear o
cualquier cosa me doy la vuelta me doy
cuenta que es una persona invidente
toma de conciencia
ese segundo mis pensamientos mis
emociones
mi actitud cambia mi realidad cambia
y en vez de querer
discutir con la persona quiero ayudarle
diga señor estamos en rojo agárrense de
mi brazo luego ayudar para cruzar cambia
mi realidad esos son los momentos world
esos son los momentos de verdad que
necesitamos para avanzar para crecer
para aprender
y algo que hacemos que todo líder y que
ahora todos somos líderes no es cierto
necesitamos desarrollar nuestra mente y
nuestro corazón
y la mente si lo podemos ver con el
indicador de la tele y el coeficiente de
inteligencia según los estudiosos los
expertos esto es algo que no se puede
mover y que lo tienes desde nacimiento o
desde los 18 años sin embargo tú el eco
que está en inglés para inteligencia
emocional si la puedes desarrollar si
puedes trabajar en eso
entonces
para un poco de darles un ejemplo de lo
que es una herramienta de inteligencia
dimensional de darme cuenta de algo que
antes no me daba cuenta y lo que decimos
en este vídeo que les voy a mostrar que
se llama el llamado es de diferenciar
entre un hecho y una interpretación
entre un hecho y una opinión veamos el
vídeo presta la atención
así
realmente es una energía muy positiva
atenderá tranquila
[Música]
hola hija todo bien fin decidí me
saliste bien abrigados novia tengo un
problema con el auto pero bueno tócame
la puerta cuando llegas bueno fue citado
[Música]
a tener tele tranquila
estas compras en fin tiene un aro en la
cara y del 1 al 5 toneladas
acá tengo 6 casi 102 kilos para la
visita
me tengo que ir
y
puede
bien espero que nadie le haya sucedido
esto por el muchacho en base a una
interpretación toma una decisión
equivocada
y eso es darse cuenta de algo cómo darse
cuenta de este pequeño ejercicio que me
encanta
eres feliz sí o no si la respuesta es sí
obviamente sigue haciendo lo mismo
aquí viene lo interesante si la
respuesta es no eres feliz no me
pregunto quieres ser feliz obvio
entonces cambia algo
sin embargo los seres humanos
queremos ser felices pero seguimos
haciendo lo mismo eso es lo que llamamos
gran albert dijo los cura es hacer la
misma cosa y una y otra vez esperando
obtener resultados diferentes
entonces esta es una oportunidad
y quiero hacerles la pregunta asumamos
por un instante
asumamos por un instante que esta charla
ha sido diseñada especialmente para cada
uno de ustedes
para el crecimiento personal y en tu
liderazgo de cada uno de ustedes qué
oportunidades hay
por qué
las oportunidades van a venir siempre
la pregunta es estás preparado o no cómo
va tu auto liderazgo
entonces levanten la mano quienes son
líderes
quienes son líderes excelente excelente
todos somos líderes todos tenemos ese
poder de la influencia te atreves a
servir entonces a la cuenta de tres les
voy a pedir que repitan y hagamos de
escuchar hasta la plaza
yo soy un líder y me atrevo a servir a
la una a las dos ya las 3 yo
excelente no ganamos la mano del corazón
mismo a la una a las dos y a las tres
yo soy vida
celeste gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]